it is the official kickoff for walker
furniture's 27th home for the holidays
program
in which they donate households of
furniture to 35
families in need in our community linda
alterwitz missouri
owner of walker furniture is joining us
to tell us more about the program
that has been going on for so long and
has done so much good linda
how do you even select recipients
well first of all it's been going on for
27 years
which uh which we're really proud of um
we get almost close to a thousand
letters per year
and we invite how it works is we invite
the community
to write in a letter about someone in
need this year
whether it's a family member a neighbor
a friend and
tell us their story tell us what's going
on and
from all those selections we uh
we ask helping hands of nevada
to help us uh with that with that
large number of letters and they read
every single
letter uh and then they
narrow it down from all those letters to
about a hundred to 200
letters and then they make home visits
to verify the need
so they narrow it down to 45 and then
our amazing executive committee
does the final 35 recipients
yeah and i've had the the honor of being
part of that
for many years and i can't believe
how difficult it is because each and
every letter of those 45 that you guys
um send our way is
gut-wrenching and and heart-rending
because these are people in need these
are people who have been through a lot
and what you're bringing them is um some
solace in a
very very difficult time so it's it's
amazing what you guys
do tell us what each family will receive
well pretty much an entire household of
furniture
and living room dining room bedroom and
for instance if they have six
children each child will get their own
bed or
worth three sets of bunk beds um and
it's customized to the needs of the
family
and where they're living it's incredible
how can the community get involved
well you can write letters in about
somebody
that you know and go onto our website at
www.walkerfurniturehomefortheholidays.com
the easiest way to do is to submit it
electronically
or you could mail in a letter or stop by
either of our two locations one in
las vegas and one in henderson and just
let us know what's going on
with with the family or the individual
linda the generosity is amazing you have
helped so many families over the years
thank you thank you thank you
thanks for joining us today thank you
thank you walker furniture has two
locations they have one in las vegas and
one in henderson
those addresses are on your screen you
can also call them at that phone number
702-384-9300 or visit
walkerfurniture.com